Halloween is just a few days away and you're probably trying to nail down the perfect costume.
So we've got some dos and don'ts from Hollywood's hottest celebs.
Katy Perry can look cute in just about anything.
But with a cheesetastic mustache? Not so much.
We give Katy credit for getting the look of Queen frontman Freddie Mercury spot-on,...
...but overall, this costume didn't exactly rock us.
Heidi Klum as Betty Boop? Do!
Heidi Klum as a scary blue Indian goddess? Don't!
Do not!
Couple's costumes are always fun,...
...but they can be tricky.
Rick Fox and Eliza Dushku look badass as undead gangsters.
And we dig on Nick and Mariah as imperfect angels.
It says it right on her glove.
Kelly Osbourne and her then boyfriend Luke Worrall went the silly route as bacon and eggs,...
...but Ice-T and his wife Coco scared us not in a good way with this getup.
What's up with that ball gag?
Finally, check out this twitpic from "Modern Family" star Sofia Vergara and her on-screen son Rico Rodriguez.
Too cute!
So, what are you gonna be for Halloween?
Send us a tweet and let us know.
For celebtv.com, I'm Kelli Zink.